[Music]
welcome back everyone so today I'm going
to tell you about a really cool
algorithm called sparse representation
for classification or SRC and this is
work that came out of this seminal 2009
paper robust face recognition via sparse
representation by Wright yang Ganesh
Shastri and MA and in some ways this may
be thought of as kind of a predecessor
of the robust principal components
analysis which came a little bit later
and so I'm gonna walk you through this
really really cool algorithm and what I
think is really neat about this the
examples they chose were very compelling
so they use this for human face
recognition so for classification of
human faces even with really really big
occlusions and kind of missing data so
in this case there are two examples kind
of in their their their main figure the
first one is a picture of a person
wearing big dark sunglasses so blocking
most of her face but through this sparse
representation for classification
algorithm this algorithm is able to
identify that this was in fact this
person so it identified her and it also
could identify kind of what her face
would look like without the glasses and
subtract those off so it can figure out
kind of who that person is and where the
biggest deviation kind of from the
original image is with which is these
big glasses so that's pretty amazing to
be able to subtract off someone's
sunglasses it's almost like x-ray vision
and that's a pretty cool cool algorithm
here you have a similar image actually
the same person with tons and tons of
kind of noise on this image and again
through this procedure somehow for a
computer for this algorithm there still
is enough information in this image to
cross-reference it against the library
and identify this person so I'm gonna
walk you through this algorithm today
and kind of show you how it works
again I'll point out that you can find
more about this in chapter 3 of our
textbook by myself and Nathan Cutts
data-driven science and engineering you
can download the whole PDF here
all of the code in MATLAB and in Python
is available at databook UW comm and on
github so please download this code try
it yourself this is super interesting
and again if you find this useful like
and subscribe hit the bell and write
comments about what you like or don't
like or what you want to see more of ok
so back to how this algorithm actually
works I'm gonna walk you through kind of
the high level of what SRC does and how
it works and this is from our text this
example is from our textbook so the
basic idea is going to be kind of
leveraging robust statistics and the
fact that patterns exist in your data so
you have this library of human face
images and we're going to use that along
with sparsity to cross-reference to
cross-reference these images so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna take an
image of a person and the first thing
we're gonna do is we're gonna down
sample it so that it's a really really
coarse version of that image I mean look
you can barely tell that this is that
person at all ok but that's the down
sampled image and then we're gonna take
that down sampled image and we're gonna
stack that as a tall skinny vector with
I don't know in this case maybe there
are a couple of hundred elements of this
vector maybe a hundred elements of this
vector ok and we're going to do that
this is the important part we're gonna
do that for every single image of every
single person in a large database so you
can imagine kind of this might be the
Facebook database or you know some FBI
database or whatever but a big library
of human images cropped in a line so
that you can do a singular value
decomposition or a principal component
analysis and what we're gonna do so this
is the Yale be faces data set where you
have 36 people for each of those people
you have 64 images from different
lighting conditions and you can see up
here this is kind of that library down
sampled and reshaped as column vectors
so this seventh person here is this
whole kind of band of columns right this
is 64 columns all for that one person
and every single person gets their own
64 columns and this mass
massive massive library okay and now
this is you might be wondering why did
we dam down sample the image that seems
silly there's so much more information
here than there is here now the trick
here is that we're able to use sparse
regression and kind of ideas from
compressed sensing and sparse
representation when this vector is much
smaller than the number of columns in
our library so we have to down sample
our high-res image so that it has less
rows than the number of columns in our
library and when we do that this becomes
a really really kind of interesting
underdetermined
optimization problem or underdetermined
regression problem and we've seen this a
lot in compressed sensing this is a lot
like the compressed sensing problem what
we're gonna try to do is find some very
sparse linear combination of the columns
in our in our library that add up to
equal this column vector right here okay
this this kind of test measurement that
we have and again for that compressed
sensing trick to work we need the number
of measurements to be less than the
number of columns in this this this
matrix now this is technically not
compressed sensing this really is a
different animal altogether called
sparse representation but it's very
similar to what we've been talking about
in sparse optimization okay so what
we're gonna do here is we're going to
solve this sparse optimization problem
we're gonna find the minimum the fewest
columns in this library of faces that
add up to equal this column so we want
to find the so here you can see my
coefficient vector this is the
coefficients that I multiply by all of
these columns to add up to equal this
one and the goal here is for this
coefficient vector to be as sparse as
possible and in fact you can see that
there are only a couple of nonzero
entries here right here and those
correspond to entries in this part of
the library right here corresponding to
person 7/7 entry in the library okay
so so that's really kind of the whole
game here is you you take
your image and a whole library of images
you downsampled them so that the the
kind of number of entries in a column
vector are less than the number of
columns in the library and then you do
this sparse representation optimization
so you can represent this column
sparsely in this library okay
so these are often called atoms in a
basis and you're trying to find a sparse
representation of the new image in this
library okay and then when you get the
sparse vector of coefficients now what
you do so this is literally the vector
of coefficients here okay and you can
see that only a very few of these are
nonzero and they happen to be in the
library corresponding to one of our
people and so then this is the really
interesting part so all I've told you
right now is just sparse representation
the classification step comes at the end
so now I have this sparse vector of
coefficients have done the sparse
representation now what we do is we go
person by person along this library and
we only use those coefficients for the
first person so these coefficients here
and we see how good if I only use those
coefficients and this part of the
library how much error would I have in
approximating this vector that's this
bar here in my bar chart okay and my
error is really really large it's like
order one error that's terrible then I
do that for person two in the person to
library so I go over here to my second
column and my second set of coefficients
I see how well that does it
approximating I also get a lot of error
for person two same with person three
person four person five and so on until
I get to person seven and that is this
guy's actually from he is person seven
so by the time I get to person seven now
I am in a part of my sparse vector that
actually has nonzero entries and so when
I multiply these coefficients for person
seven by that part of the library I
actually get a pretty good approximation
in this column vector and I get a
relatively low error here okay I get
relatively low error compared with all
of the other representations for all of
the other people okay so this does
require the in your library you have
examples from many classes for many
categories that you have labels for you
know whose person wanted person to in
person 3 and then when you go and do is
you go once you have this sparse
coefficient vector you go person by
person and you see how good would that
those coefficients do with person one
estimating this image with person 2
estimating this image and this is
actually extremely effective this is a
very very clear indicator that this
image came from person 7 ok so this is
how you classify images using SRC and
it's all based on this idea of sparse
representation in a library okay so
we're gonna sparsely approximate this
new person in this library and then
we're going to see kind of where does
the sparse kind of the non 0 support
live that's very likely where that
person lives ok so that's how you do SRC
and just some cool examples so here you
have kind of just an original face this
is a face with no noise added no funny
mustache nothing we coarse-grain it we
run it through that optimization and
again you see very very clearly that
there is activity in one region of this
library and that region again
corresponds to person 7 so the predicted
image is very similar to the original
image and this original this image did
not have to be in that library I think I
actually removed this image from that
library or else that would be kind of
cheating or else it would just be a
single delta function on that on that
image so this is a real test image this
is not in the library but there are
other images of this person's face and
it finds the closest one it actually
finds the closest to and interpolates
between them ok and then going back to
our mustache example you can take your
mustache and down sample I think
probably there I was a little I made a
mistake on the error bar on my first
plot over here this one should have had
a little bit higher error I think I just
copied the wrong the wrong image but you
get the idea even with a mustache with a
pretty big outlier
or occlusion here this information that
still has enough information in the eyes
and the nose and the chin to accurately
reconstruct that person's face now again
the error you can also get a predicted
error between this image and the
prediction and you see that most of it
lives in this mustache you can also add
a bunch of either salt-and-pepper noise
or white noise in this case this is
actually surprisingly hard for the
algorithm this kind of salt-and-pepper
noise really messes things up and you
get relatively large errors here so
that's that's a little surprising you
can also do it with like white noise
white noise is a little bit easier for
this and you get relatively low low
reconstruction errors okay so that's
kind of the big idea behind sparse
representation and then sparse
representation for classification is
that you can have a big library of
training data and as long as your your
measurement is kind of has less entries
less rows than columns in your library
you can do this sparse representation
trick to find a few combinations of your
library that add up to your to your your
new test vector and then if that have if
that library also has categories you can
use this for classification like image
classification okay so that's pretty
useful I encourage you to try this out
it's really cool and you can actually
use this in all kinds of applications in
science and engineering so I'll give you
just kind of a teaser of how to do that
I want to point out this really
interesting paper by bright Lin and cuts
from 2013 so this is actually a very
forward-looking paper here they used
sparse ideas from kind of compressed
sensing and sparse representation for
physical sciences for engineering
systems pretty early so this was before
a lot of other people had kind of gotten
on the sparsity bandwagon and really
started to use this this is one of the
earliest papers applying these sparse
representation ideas for engineering
systems and in this example what they
were able to do they were taking these
fluid flows past a cylinder examples of
kind of canonical fluid flows and
on very very small amounts of sensors
very few sensors on the surface of the
cylinder they were able to estimate what
Reynolds number the flow was at so it's
a really cool kind of classification
problem was it a high Reynolds number a
medium Reynolds number or a low Reynolds
number I think they had six categories
of Reynolds numbers and so that was a
really really neat kind of problem they
could also reconstruct the flow field
once they had found that part of the
library so once they found where in
Reynolds number their flow was they
could use those measurements to estimate
the flow field so very very cool and
very ahead of its time and I'm gonna
also point out that recently Jarrod
Callaham Kazuki Maite and myself applied
this to kind of a wider variety of flows
to see what types of measurements you
could get away with what types of noise
you could get away with and really do
kind of an exhaustive study of how this
scales up to more complex fluid flow
problems so this is very much like what
we described in the the SRC sparse
representation for for classification
algorithm but here we're using sparse
representation for flow field
reconstruction for full estimation of
the full flow field okay so we're not
just trying to classify is it flow a or
flow B we're trying to get all of the
subtle details of this fluid flow so
that's a month that's a very hard
problem so here we have in this example
problem a large library of training data
of that flow past a cylinder we and for
every image in that training set we
measure at a fixed set of locations I
think here there's five locations and so
every column of our library are those
five measurements at a particular
instant in time those five measurements
at another instant of time another
instant other instant another instant
and so on so that's how we build our
library
that's an expensive offline training you
can do that on a supercomputer over the
weekend let it run and now when you're
doing this online you're collecting
measurements in the field you're
measuring at those same five locations
on a really noisy field and we're trying
to do a sparse representation of that
new noisy measurement in our library and
the same thing that worked for images
works here for flow fields you get the
sparse vector representing my new
measurement in my library and it does in
fact actually correspond to the correct
phase and so you can use that to
reconstruct the full flow estimate and
and effectively denoise even from a very
small number of very noisy measurements
I have five super noisy measurements you
can actually estimate the flow field so
this is great work by Jared Callaham I
encourage you to check out the paper
either in physical review fluids or on
the archive he also showed that on this
example you could apply this to lots and
lots of different measurement strategies
including kind of random points in the
wake or a vertical slice of measurements
a horizontal slice of measurements or a
window this would kind of represent like
a PIV window and fluids and he goes and
shows like even with really really
corrupt measurements like 80 percent
corruption on the measurements depending
on the types of measurements you have
you can actually get very faithful
reconstructed flow fields now that's not
so surprising for this example because
the flow past a cylinder is very low
dimensional very low rank it's described
by really only a few numbers in the
right coordinate system and so what
Jared did was then scale this up to many
more complex flows so this is sea
surface temperature across the globe
this is the the vorticity field in the
Gulf of Mexico and this is a mixing
layer so these are all pretty
complicated or rather you know these
three are definitely more complicated
than the cylinder and so you can go
check out in the paper kind of what
works what carries over what doesn't and
when this method breaks for really
really complex flows kind of a tease or
something I think is really interesting
is that if you're using measurements
kind of upstream in this flow so let's
say I measure some stuff here it turns
out that because this flow is chaotic
for the same upstream measurements there
might be many many different things you
can see downstream and so there's this D
correlation length spatially in these
physical problems which means that
sensors up here the information content
of how that affects flow structure is
down here kind of degrades as you're
measurement and estimation windows get
farther and farther apart so that's a
really interesting kind of physical
connection for for flow fields at least
but there's also you know you can do the
same thing for images you can figure out
what regions of the face if I occluded
have the most information and will give
me kind of the most degradation in my
reconstruction okay so I hope you found
that interesting sparse representation
and sparse representation for
classification are absolutely
phenomenally powerful algorithms you can
use these for classical signal
processing image processing but you can
also apply these to modern engineering
systems and data systems and this is
very closely related to ideas and
machine learning and kind of data
science in general where you're trying
to take patterns in the data and
leverage those patterns with
optimization in this case sparse
optimization to achieve a goal that
seems like it is really kind of almost
you know impossible or magical right
like you know subtract the sunglasses
off of a picture x-ray vision
classify an image from a very
downsampled version of it okay so really
cool what you can do I encourage you to
try this all out for yourself thank you